oh ouais salut salut je suis Mike je n'ai jamais vraiment
activement celui que je pensais être plutôt
cool tu veux vraiment vraiment faire partie
de ton film lumineux c'est juste un grand
film et me rappelle beaucoup d'aliénation
j'aime bien si tu  les gars pensent une suite
j'espère vraiment que vous pouvez inclure l'unité
je peux faire de l'action pourrait être joel
edgerton se sentir partie prenante du
processus créatif même je peux jouer le mort
Will Smith oh wow votre honneur honnêtement
elle travaillait juste était Will Smith qui
ferait  ma vie essayant d'avoir
à nouveau des démons autour de lui, tournez-vous vers ce qu'il faut manger votre réception corporelle en
cessant juste l'adversaire si
bien en lâchant les canards je ce qui a mis
l'ambiance si vous jouez à Shadowrun,
nous pourrions jouer ensemble